for our daily cancellation i cannot say
that it's a major shock by any means but
in recent weeks i have learned that the
starbucks baristas community includes
some of the whiniest most self-pitying
humans
who have ever existed on the face of the
planet now this doesn't apply to all of
them there are exceptions of course but
the whiners are a large enough
contingent so that every week it would
seem there's another viral post on
twitter from a barista complaining about
customers about working conditions about
the lack of pay the lack of tips etc but
the one thing that this group hates the
most it seems
is when they're asked to do the job they
signed up for so earlier this week on
twitter
it was posted a thread
with instructions someone posted a
thread with instructions on how to order
various fancy frappuccino drinks and
lattes
these are not on the drive-through menu
but they're drinks that starbucks can
make if you ask
and uh they're kind of complicated now
i'm i'm personally not one to order
fancy drinks and i can't say that i
particularly enjoy
being stuck in line behind a fancy drink
enthusiast but this is why the baristas
are there it's why they have jobs if
everybody was like me and simply wanted
a humble medium roast coffee about 80 of
starbucks staff would just become
immediately useless we wouldn't need
them
and yet many members of the starbucks
team responded to the tweet complaining
bitterly about the very customers who
saved them from redundancy so i'll read
a few of these responses which are
representative of many others
quote hey just so you know baristas
despise these hyper-customized drinks it
throws us off our rhythm starbucks
understaffs us and expects us to make a
drink every 48 seconds drinks that
aren't routine take longer and put us
behind in a stressful environment try
ordering a latte another one says
imagine pumping out 120 plus drinks an
hour and having to clear the drive
through in less than 46 seconds this
isn't cute it's labor abuse
yes that's right it is abusive for a
customer to ask a customer service
worker to provide them with
service
another comment says each of these
drinks is going to cost at least nine
dollars because of all the additions
also your baristas will hate you
and indeed many other baristas confirm
this some threatening physical violence
against any customer who dares to make
them get off their asses and do the job
they're paid to do but twitter's not the
only forum for these uh bitching
baristas tick tock has become so far as
i can tell
also um a forum really really a forum
primarily
for dancing
and also for barista complaints and
sometimes for barista complaints in the
form of dancing
so the daily dot reports on one recent
example quote a barista is going viral
on tick tock after uploading a routine
customer experience he has while making
drinks that have cold foam in them
marquis maynell said in a caption for
the popular clip which garnered a
hundred thousand likes on the social
media platform that it happens daily
several other baristas in the comment
section said that they've experienced
the same type of anxious requests from
patrons that they've served as well the
video video begins with marquis setting
down a cup of cold brew um it's an iced
coffee with a text overlay that reads
okay and here's the cold brew let me add
your cold foam the barista then starts
adding the foam to the cup before
another text overlay meant to represent
an interjecting customer comes up on the
screen don't forget my cold phone it
reads marquis adds the foam to the drink
which he was in the middle of doing in
the video before the customer reminded
him not to pour it in their cup he then
gives the customer a glare before
walking off camera now by the way
he was actually at starbucks apparently
on the clock when he made this video
complaining about the customers at
starbucks
so this is another very common thing
like these starbucks employees are
making videos complaining about their
job while on the job
so the next time you're sitting in line
at starbucks wondering what's taking so
long keep in mind that they they you you
might be getting held up because the
employees haven't finished uploading
their tick tocks yet in a society rife
with anti-religious ideologies like the
ones we hear from the left on a daily
basis it can be incredibly challenging
to ground oneself in what we know to be
true and good to keep from descending
into distrust frustration or even hatred
that's why i find god's peace every day
through prayer and meditation with
hallow hallow is the number one
christian prayer app in the us and the
number one catholic app in the world
that's rooted in catholic tradition but
it's an amazing resource for any
christian looking to dive deeper into
their prayer life hallow has prayers and
meditation to guide you throughout your
entire day morning to night some of the
most popular prayers include the daily
rosary gospel reading the daily psalm
with bishop baron there's the bible in a
year very popular with father mike
schmitz meditations for sleep kids
prayers and much more hello keeps helps
me find peace and calm throughout the
day helps me sleep better lowers my
anxiety levels teaches my kids not to be
terrible terrible humans all of that so
you can go and let hallow help you find
your peace and strengthen your faith
also by going to hallow.com matt walsh
and get an extended three-month free
trial during which you'll have access to
all 5 000 plus meditations and prayers
you get all of that at hallow.com matt
walsh for three months free reclaim your
piece in this crazy world download hello
today
another tick tock video has this caption
on the screen quote just reminding
everyone that starbucks baristas can see
you in the drive-through when you're at
the box so i saw you make faces and
throw your hands up and say stuff under
your breath to your friend because i
asked you what size pink drink you
wanted i'm sorry i didn't hear you the
first time
i didn't mean to offend you another
barista agreed with this warning
customers that if she doesn't like your
attitude of the drive-through line she
will intentionally make your order wrong
so there's another recent tick tock
video featuring a barista complaining
about people who order frappuccinos too
early in the morning
i've also heard complaints about people
who order complicated drinks too close
to closing time so
don't order them in the morning
don't order them at night
don't order them in the afternoon
because that's when all the workers are
making tick tock videos just don't order
the drinks at all
don't go to starbucks because your
presence is an imposition on the
employees but also
the employees all need higher wages so
this is what they demand
less business less work
higher wages
economics 101 folks
now here's the point that needs to be
made
and it's not just baristas who need to
hear this
yes they seem to be an especially
aggrieved bunch
constantly persecuted by customers who
you know order things
but this is a symptom of a widespread
cultural epidemic we hear constant
complaints from all sectors of the
working world among high and low paid
workers even hollywood actresses worth
millions like jennifer lawrence will
still relentlessly complain about their
jobs
now if there's legitimate abuse going on
actual injustice
then those should be exposed and
addressed but someone making a
complicated order or getting a little
annoyed with you is not abuse and it's
not an injustice
it's just the job it's the job you
signed up for it's the reason your
position exists
so here are some things that anyone
should think about before they start
whining and moaning about their job and
this this no matter what your job is
this goes for starbucks baristas people
in my line of work whatever it is number
one
your job is not as difficult or taxing
as you think it is
has its challenges
but there are many jobs more difficult
than yours
every job has its own sources of
frustration this is the other thing you
hear from baristas anytime you talk
about this and they're complaining and
you say you shouldn't come by you tried
doing this sometime you can't imagine
how hard this is you could never do this
but try working a customer service job i
mean i've done that lots of us have i'm
not saying it has its difficulties it is
kind of stressful but it's not it's it's
something that a lot of us have done and
can do
your job is not as difficult as you
think
two um also remember that you pursued
this job you asked for it you went to
the employer and said can i have this
job please i want to do this
and then they said yes you can do it
here are your job responsibilities and
you said yes i'll do those
responsibilities
look there are people who don't have a
job and would love to take yours if it's
such a burden also keep that in mind
three you don't deserve any special
commendations simply for showing up you
have to work and
even when you work
you still don't deserve special
commendation just for that it's what's
expected it's your responsibilities your
duty you aren't a martyr simply
fulfilling your basic responsibilities
four
successful people
are always the ones who go to their jobs
looking to add extra challenges to their
day
that might sound like it might might
throw you for a loop it might sound
crazy but people who are really
successful they that's what they do no
matter what their line of work is they
go into their job and they're looking
actually to make the job harder they're
looking for more challenges more things
to do
they want to challenge themselves at the
job
and if that sounds if that sounds
mind-boggling to you can't even imagine
someone doing that
well it's why you are not as successful
as you could be
if you sit around all day you know
dwelling on the difficulties of your
work and trying to avoid them you will
languish in mediocrity forever you will
never be successful you will never
amount to anything
worthwhile
and five most importantly and here i
climb atop uh a familiar soapbox once
again
but i have to just say it the the
my classic dad's speech
life is work there is no such thing as a
work-free life every life requires work
to sustain it either you will do that
work for yourself or someone else will
be made to do it for you now the latter
option may seem attractive but there's
no honor in it and there's no success in
it there's no happiness and it's
certainly not the ethical approach it's
also not an option for most people
no
in your case most likely just like in my
case
we have to work we have no choice that's
it that's life it just is
it's it's the nature of human existence
so you might as well put some effort in
and have a good attitude about it and
strive for success you have you have to
do this so you can sit around
complaining all day it's too hard i want
to do it it's so difficult but it
doesn't matter you're alive you're a
human this is just what life is
so you might as well accept it
and try to make the most of it
and one more guideline if you're going
to complain about your job if you are
going to complain about it and i'm not
we all complain about our job sometimes
but if you are gonna do it
do it in the break room in whispers like
a normal person don't do it on the
internet
these starbuck baristas have have
violated all of these rules in
particular though they violate that last
one
and so that is why finally
they are the ones who are today
cancelled
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts